could speak with you again Brady what's
going on man not much just out here in
LA right now going through some
rehearsals preparing ourselves for you
know what it's gonna be a big weekend
for us kind of kicking off kicking off
our big noon kickoff for Fox Sports okay
who's the biggest Steve on set so far
Brady that's a good question I mean like
is is is urban demanding
room-temperature water and a certain of
mmm he's probably as like low
maintenance as possible I would say so
far yes happy Rob stone or Reggie Bush I
was like one of those do right now is
that a hair product situation as of
right now is that a hair product
situation so what you're saying is here
right now okay that before my issues the
hair product I'm gonna steal as much as
I can from wider look at that mop that
he's got he's got so much stuff in there
that's not really much leftover
communities so after the game in which
Reggie clearly pushed Matt Leinart into
the end zone
to beat you Brady if I put all three of
you together to say one day you'd be on
the same television set for a crucial
venture for Fox Sports and college
football what would you have said well
now that you put it that way rich
there's no chance that would ever happen
I never really thought of it that way
but I guess you bring you back some old
memories they don't really fit you well
and I'm constantly reminded of that
we've got a couple segments where I hope
you were reminded of that throughout the
course of the year so little
foreshadowing to what you can expect to
see but you know Reggie Bush was the
best college football player that I've
ever seen and and I say this all the
time I tried to recruit him to come to
Notre Dame right submitted I called him
I kind of told him kind of pitched the
plan we had a great class coming in that
that second year for Tyrone Willingham
really his first four-year recruiting
and and I tried to give my best pitch to
him and I really feel like I selling
this to this day had he gone to Notre
Dame he would have been a 2-time Heisman
Trophy winner because he would have
played right away and with the notoriety
and everything else from it and as good
as a player he was
I think you would have wanted twice but
you know obviously didn't work out that
way the liner gets him in as his
teammate and kind of the rest is history
but you know the funny thing about that
game is you know those guys are very
unapologetic about what they did in
order to win the game and I can't blame
them but it just seems like it's so
status quo for some USC people right now
yeah so they do so it's now out in the
open right I mean they fully admit that
that was a shove that's clearly beyond
the the swirl right it was illegal now
it's legal right was illegal now it's
legal so you see it actually often now
and I think that's that's what makes
them feel like it's okay cuz they're
like well it was illegal then but now
it's legal it was we were just behind
the times back then so when you say
there's gonna be segments when he's
trying to talk about who should be in it
win the heisman are we gonna call that
bushes push is that what he say or he
Gamble's and looks like green room and
race what's that look like green room it
I know you know that's a term that
you're very familiar with I'm sure so
you got you got to tune in to watch it
was gonna all what comes out from it why
actually I use the term save the gold
you got to save the gold save the gold
giving you gold I'm trying look you know
obviously you've got some talented
people there at Fox you can figure this
whole thing out for yourself and then
you know there is a conversation in
urban actually took to his Twitter
account to try and tamp it one that
shouldn't say tamp it down to reframe
that he never really said Trevor
Lawrence is the most talented
quarterback he's ever seen walk me
through what he did say and what he
means and where this all sits right now
Brady yeah it was actually hilarious
because I work for CBS on their digital
platform side and when I was going into
work after we had been out and taping
that show producer it hit me up and said
hey sir but think sir Lawrence was the
best quarterback ever and I said well no
chance that's that's right whoever wrote
that or thinks that he said that at some
point because it's always going to be
Tim you know Tim Tebow and their
relationship they're still very close to
this day you'd be hard-pressed to ever
find someone that whatever surpassed him
in that light so when when he showed me
the clip I'm like well I can understand
how people could
see that he said ever instead of saying
however but when we were on set it was
very clear you know he said Trevor
Lawrence is the best quarterback in
football however and then he went on to
make his next point
he didn't say ever and that's where in
this day of you know media and
journalism you know it unfortunately got
misconstrued that he said ever and then
people are running with it when it was
actually pretty inaccurate yeah he said
however what about the rest of the team
so let's continue that thought right now
first things first you see the best
quarterback in college football because
all I know right now is NFL teams are
salivating over the chance to draft tool
next year and then you got a kid up in
Oregon who is no slouch in his own right
so where do you stand on that subject
yeah I think it's interesting because
you're asking me what are you basically
projected me as an NFL prospect and what
he is is a college quarterback I mean
those are two different conversations
right because I think to uh maybe a
better college quarterback if I was a
betting man I probably say to is
probably going to win the Heisman this
year and I could give you some reasons
for that but then when I watched to his
game and I break him down on film versus
Trevor Lawrence
I think Trevor would be a better
prospect prospect for the next level so
you know they're kind of two different
answers but I would say Trevor is right
they're neck-and-neck if not you know
this year has the ability to sophomore
year to take that stride to be better
but but to is pretty darn good I mean
it's really tough when you watch them on
film and some of the special things you
could do to buy time and create plays
and make you know awkward throws it's
just I mean it's it's seldom seen in
college football I mean it reminds you a
lot of Russell Wilson but obviously as a
left hander even with all the talent
he's got so I would say they're
neck-and-neck I get the edge of the tour
right now but I cannot want to see more
of Trevor Lawrence and maybe that
opinion opinion will change this year
well Brady Quinn here on the Rich Eisen
show from Fox Sports yeah I mean in
terms of an NFL prospect you mentioned
Russell Wilson obviously and Baker
Mayfield is a guy whose
Heights was discussed prior to him being
number one overall and then waking up
dangerous pretty much every single day
after that don't you think we need to
see what Kyler Murray looks like this
year cuz if he does perform to the
manner that the Cardinals and Kliff
Kingsbury I hope he can perform that
might make to a a full-on bright shining
NFL star prospect of say Trevor
Lawrence's level
wouldn't you say Brady sure sure I mean
and look
cooking is very not been Sega's the head
coach and in Arizona you know calimary
probably doesn't go number one overall
and and reason being is he's the perfect
fit for what cliff wants to do and is
trying to bring to the NFL it's another
team that doesn't have that sort of
system you know they might not look as
favorably towards calimary so so who
knows how the draft would have worked
out if it's Kliff Kingsbury wasn't there
and they didn't go all in on this vision
of what they want their offense to be
compared to what it was last year but
you know there's no doubt that people
like I mean even drew Brees for being a
shorter quarterback and you know I had
started to pave the way for the Russell
Wilson's and obviously a Baker Mayfield
and now calimary and I think NFL is
getting to a points you were for me I
think what makes caliber e
so special forget about the height for a
second it's the fact that he can make a
bad play guilt he could turn something
that's really not going to work into a
positive gain and and that there's the
biggest mismatch right now in the field
is the defensive line versus the
offensive line it's getting harder and
harder to develop and find these
offensive linemen that's why you see
darts now being taken in the top ten
because they need to find the best studs
they can up front to protect these guys
and if not these guys have to be mobile
enough to be able to move out and create
some plays with their legs and so if
Colin Murray is special at doing that
which I think he is hmm you know you can
then look at taking a shorter guy
because he'll find a way of finding
space to make throws regardless of what
his height is and then let's finish the
thought again that sparked this whole
conversation with Urban Meyer however
what about the rest of the team meaning
Clemson so what do you think
yeah no it's it's to me it's Clemson
Alabama those are that the top two teams
in college football and it's kind of
everyone else and there's some teams I
think that you can make a case for every
conference with with the exception of
Clemson I think Clemson is by far and
away the best team in the ACC and then
you know Syracuse is ranked now I don't
know what they'll be this year they've
lost some pieces I'll see there's their
quarterback too so you know that's gonna
impact them moving forward but you look
at the SEC George is probably right
there LSU is a team that's gonna compete
in the SEC West with Alabama you know
you go out to pac-12 it's Oregon in the
Utah big tenants Ohio State Michigan
there every conference I think pretty
much has two teams that are distinctly
the best now with the exception of the
ACC but I think an overall on college
football it's still Bama Clemson and
we're probably going to see them in the
college football playoff again this year
as the poll question to Brady who since
it's kind of dovetailing into this
conversation Chris yeah Brady who do you
got to win the championship however
Clemson Alabama or the field
I'll take Alabama well I just I feel
like this is one of those spots where
it's like a revenge game for saving it's
a revenge game for two uh you know those
guys are probably looking their chops
and I know they just lost you know
Dillon Moses there's their linebacker
but they've recruited well and I think
they'll be able to overcome that maybe
they're they're so gifted at the wide
receiver position - I just have a hard
time believing that anyone who wants to
try to face them and attract me is going
to be able to cover any of those guys I
mean Jerry Judy's a stud wattles a stud
Riggs I mean you could go on down the
line but these guys are all studs that
they've got so I just I think it's going
to be kind of a revenge factor this year
for them and people can talk about the
transition on the coaching staff but I
mean Nick Saban's dealt with this before
kind of built Bella second the Patriots
and all the guys they end up losing they
just kind of replenish reload and they
go in the AFC East again I think that's
kind of what I foresee happening with
Alabama this year well break win here on
the Rich Eisen sure you know why
Belichick is able to do that Brady right
do you know why Belichick is able to do
that every year the point that you've
made is because he's got a Michigan man
as this quarterback Brady he's got a
Michigan man under center and sometimes
in shotgun
think you know where I'm going with that
full thing what do you consider you
consider a successful season for Notre
Dame for your alma mater what is a
successful season that starts Monday
night at Louisville well starting in
Louisville I mean I think they need to
get the bad taste out of their mouth
from the semi-final I mean honestly
that game probably until we saw the
national championship game where clubs
and just wipe the floor with Alabama
yeah it's kind of shed a bad light on
them I mean the last time they're in
that position in 2012 versus Alabama
that game didn't go well so there's the
thought of all they're not in the
conference they shouldn't be a part of
the you know the college football
playoff and then you see the national
championship game you're going okay
maybe just constant that much better
than everyone else this year and so I
think for this year for them it's about
going out and kind of proving that they
do belong to be a part of that
conversation every year their schedule
is extremely difficult you know that at
least I've got a bye before they've got
to go up to Ann Arbor and play Michigan
but you know Georgia before then they've
got to go play then down in Athens they
gotta play Stanford the end of the year
on the road and they've got seven teams
they're coming out buys they gotta
prepare for and so you've got seven
teams then out two weeks to put in
wrinkles that you don't have the
opportunity to really make adjustments
to until you know maybe the first second
third core of the game so their
schedules tough they do have a great
nucleus coming back I think their
defense has the potential to actually be
better than what it was last year and
then in book I think it take the steps
that I think they're looking for him to
take be a little bit less cautious and
take some more shots downfield they can
get to open up this offense and I would
say ten plus wins is expected and you
know if you get if you go undefeated I
do think they would win a case based on
their schedule what they went through
but being in the conversation for the
college football playoff a couple more
minutes left with Brady Quinn here of
Fox Sports now one thing that I every
single time I work with a coach on a set
as you're about to do I always look at
him and see how he reacts to watching
games
and the juices begin to get flowing and
it's never out of a coach even Mariucci
right now and I I don't think he's ever
gonna coach again but even then you just
see it in him
urban is still a relatively young man
here is there any sense that you get
right now that he still just can't shake
it maybe a little bit just cuz I think
that's what I thought that those that
are born to do and then coaches feel
that way as a player you feel like that
and so I'm sure there's gonna be moments
where we see this season him getting the
it still want to be out there and I
don't know if it's gonna be an Ohio
State game where they're struggling or
when that moments going to come but I
think he's got a good spot right now I
think he's he's trying to figure out his
process now of how he prepares himself
for this career and for life outside of
football and you know will there become
a moment with an opportunity I'm sure
there will in the future because he's
that good but you know and what will
happen at that point your guess is as
good as mine ish it but you know my
whole thing is I just want him to do
whatever makes him happy you know I
think that's for me that the biggest
thing is you know you don't want to be
working with someone who's not enjoying
what they're doing and hopefully he
enjoys our crew and enjoys what we're
doing and and this transition into this
kind of different world of broadcasting
I know he's done it before
and I think he's been open and said it
before you know they he knew when he
stepped down from Florida that he would
probably get back into coaching you know
that it didn't feel right and I think
this time around maybe feels different
for him because of where his family's at
him as a grandfather and just where he's
that person one yeah USC plays Notre
Dame right in the middle of the season
that's gonna be something on your set
not it's gonna be amazing
are you we yeah we're we were talking
about some potential ideas for surfers
and bets and what we're going to be
doing for that so it should get
interesting here in the next few days
where we come up with I know and just
and if you enjoy working with Urban
Meyer Notre Dame beating USC might
eventually cause you to lose him off the
set Brady you know just got to think of
all these are all movies yeah that would
be a tough one to swallow and when that
day comes we'll have to deal with it the
end but to cross that I tell you why
yeah the thing is bridge I think USC
will be better than what people think
this year okay they're at eight plus one
team maybe nine one team so I will see
what what that conversation is like
after this year
all right Brady I really enjoyed the
chat good good luck with the with the
new digs in Los Angeles in the studio a
year I'm sure you're gonna have a blast
and hope that means I can get you
physically in my studio very soon yeah I
would love to and I'll just say we gotta
do something for another day admission
this year right well Brady if you'd like
to do that I am all-in you want to talk
about revenge games I'm telling you what
yeah and I am ready for that one that is
gonna be just absolutely amazing that's
gonna be a Saturday night affair I am
all-in
so let's figure that out for that week
let's do it excellent Brady Quinn take
care of yourself that's Brady Quinn of
Fox Sports four more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app